Builders in Oregon will break ground
early next year on this country's
tallest building made primarily of wood
the 12 story 60 unit apartment complex
in Portland is part of a national boom
in wood construction but critics worry
timber buildings could go up in flames
Tony Tecopa is in Long Island City New
York to show us the growing movement
away from traditional high-rise
construction Tony good morning good
morning at the skyline behind me is
definitely not made of wood it is
millions of tons of concrete and steel
and for more than a century that was
really the only safe way to build high
but now for the first time more and more
architects are using a kind of
compressed wood for its strength and its
beauty but some fire experts are raising
alarms this is the tallest wood building
in the United States right now that is
right now Wow it's hard to tell from the
outside but inside Portland developer
Eric wildly walked us through the latest
milestone in wood construction a nearly
finished eighth storey condominium
complete with million-dollar apartments
and picturesque views so these beams
that's in fact what's holding the
building up correct the building known
as carbon-12 is part of a global boom in
wood construction including major
projects in Minneapolis Vancouver and
London realm of things but Glenn Corbett
a fire science professor at John Jay
College thinks wood could fuel an
inferno that firefighters can't fight
like the deadly grenfell fire in London
which climbed the building's aluminum
cladding so you think some of these new
wood high-rises could go up in flames
the way grande fell did in London yeah
because once it's over the 10th or 15
story building is no way to put water on
it it's unstoppable
basically any of the projects we're
looking at primarily wood based well
there would model Street so none of
these models are for a wood based
building architect Peter Weiss mantle
who helped design the Burj Khalifa Dubai
the world's tallest building also
worries that more wood could mean more
fire
if codes aren't strictly enforced we
have got a responsibility to think about
all the unthinkable things so I'm glad
there are advocates for timber but they
need to be reasonable
control and understanding applied to it
when you're working out of a wood office
yeah we hired at Thomas Robinson is the
lead architect for framework another
building in Portland at a hundred and
forty eight feet it's expected to
surpass carbon-12 as the tallest wood
building in America so this is the three
ply it's designed with cross laminated
timber that Robinson says is actually
fire resistant to get a building permit
in fact the material had to survive two
hours in a furnace at 2,000 degrees what
happened here
he showed us what remained of the wood
Wow so the fire burnt it down to their
exact but if this level would it still
hold it would still hold it just shows
you how the structure is durable so
durable in fact so you think there's
gonna be an explosion in this I mean you
think there's gonna be people building
these sorts of buildings all over
they're already building a number of
them in Portland you're gonna see them
all over and I should mention is these
new wood buildings they they fit
together kind of like pre-made furniture
they're pre-cut and then they snap
together framework which will be the
first wooden skyscraper in America won't
be done until about 2019 but beyond the
other building we showed you carbon-12
that will be ready any day and when it
is it will be a record holder I don't
know Tony I think I like the concrete
and steel I'm not convinced yet but
fascinating piece thank you I come from
the city thanks Tony